ALLEN ARCHULETA HERE ATKINS
BAKER GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTEZ THREE DALLY
DODD TERRAZZO EGGMAN GROWTH
HERTZBERG HUESO JONES AIRED
LEYVA MCGUIRE MELENDEZ NEWMAN
NIELSEN A TOTAL OF BOTH. PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO AMBERG BY
CAL SKI WIENER WILK. MEMBERS OF
A QUORUM IS PRESENT. WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND
THE REALM. THE MEMBERS IN OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE WORLD PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER
TODAY BY SENATOR LAYER AFTER
WHICH WILL ACTUALLY REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE WHICH
WILL BE LED TODAY BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. EARLIER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. AS WE BEGIN THE WORK
OF THIS WEEK LET US PRAY IN
GRATITUDE FOR EACH OTHER AND
FOR ALL WHO WORK ACT AND FOR
THIS STATE CAPITOL. LET US
DEDICATE OUR WEEK TO THE
PRACTICE OF HUMAN KINDNESS.
FEEL COMPASSION FOR YOURSELF AS
YOU SAY THE FOLLOWING SILENTLY.
MAY I BE HEALED MAY MY HEART
OPEN WITH KINDNESS AND PEACE
MAY I BE FILLED WITH THE SPIRIT
OF LOVE AND KINDNESS MAY I BE
HOLE. NOW CALL TO MIND ALL WHO
COLLABORATE WITH YOU EACH DAY.
HEAR YOURSELF SAYING TO THEM
MAY YOU BE HEALED MAY YOUR
HEART OPEN WITH KIND AND PEACE.
MAY YOU BE FILLED WITH THE
SPIRIT OF LOVING KINDNESS MAY
YOU BE HOLE. FINALLY OPEN YOUR
HEART IN A SPECIAL WAY TOOK ALL
YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND LET YOUR
COMPASSION EXPANDED EVEN TO OUR
WHOLE COUNTRY AND WORLD AS YOU
SAY. I ALL THINGS BE HEALED MAY
ALL BEINGS BE HAPPY. MAY ALL
BEINGS BE TOUCHED AND HEALED BY
THE FORCE OF HUMAN KINDNESS MAY
THE POWER OF OUR HEART OUR
GOODNESS OUR LOVE AND OUR
LEGISLATION BRING HEALING TO
ALL. A MAN A MAN. ME IN THE
PLEDGE READY BEGIN I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. OF THE UNITED
STATES INNER. MEMBERS TODAY WE
HAVE THE FOLLOWING SENATORS WHO
WILL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
SENATOR BATES. SENATOR GLAZER
SOONER GONZALEZ SINNERS ARE
TAUGHT ALL SENATORS LIMON
SENATOR MAN SENATOR SKINNER AND
SENATOR STERN GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS. MOVING ON NOW.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
DEAR PRESIDENT ATKINS AND
SPEAKER RENDON I HAVE
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED MY
INTENTION TO APPOINT SECRETARY
OF STATE- THE HUNDRED ALEX
VIDEO TO THE UNITED STATES
SENATE TO FILL THE VACANCY
CREATED BY THE RESIGNATION OF
COMILLA D. HARRIS TO BECOME
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES. EARLIER TODAY JANUARY
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SENATOR DESIGNATE IDEA
ACCORDINGLY RESIGNED AS
SECRETARY OF STATE THIS
RESIGNATION CREATES AN
IMMEDIATE VACANCY IN THE OFFICE
OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE
PURSUANT TO ARTICLE FIVE
SECTION FIVE SUBDIVISION B. OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION AND
SECTION SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
OF THE GOVERNMENT CODE I HEREBY
NOMINATE THE FOLLOWING PERSON
TO FILL THAT VACANCY FOR THE
BALANCE OF THE UEXPIRED TERM.
DR SURELY NASH WEBER MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
SEVENTY NINE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
JOINT TO SECTION SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE OF THE GOVERNMENT
CODE THE CHIEF DEPUTY. TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE SHALL
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES OF THAT
OFFICE UNTIL THE VACANCY IS
FILLED SINCERELY GAVIN NEWSOM
GOVERNOR. THANK YOU MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE
DEEMED READ. REPORTS FROM
COMMITTEE WILL BE ROUTINE READ.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTERJECTIONS OF THE
FIRST READING MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE THREE. SENATE BILLS. TO
TWENTY NINE TO THIRTY TWO
THIRTY ONE TO THIRTY TWO AND
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY THREE.
IF THERE'S NO FURTHER BUSINESS
INTERACTIONS THE DECIS COLOR.
KELLY THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU- WELCOME BACK AND-
GOOD TO SEE YOU BRIEFLY AND WE
WILL- HAVE THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION SCHEDULED FOR THIS
THURSDAY JANUARY TWENTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU MA'AM FOR TOMB THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WILL RECONVENE ON
THURSDAY AT NINE AM. SENATE
THIS HOURS.